[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour une émission spéciale
avec l'un des intellectuels les plus
originaux de notre époque le philosophe
alain deneault directeur de programme au
collège international de la philosophie
de paris deux philosophies de paris plus
exactement c'est l'auteur de la
médiocratie
il se lance dans un feuilleton théorique
en publiant trois livres en même temps
aux éditions lux l'économie de la nature
l'économie de la fois l'économie
esthétique n'étiez pas venu depuis un an
et demi à peu près enfants vous êtes
canadien alain deneault est ce que vous
avez trouvé ce pays change eh ben je
viens à peu près onze ans et demi et à
chaque fois je vois une évolution par
à-coups cette fois comme être dans le
continuum
je remarque très certainement que à
chaque occasion
il ya une raison de mettre les gens sous
pression bon là c'est un virus avant
c'était le terrorisme avant c'est autre
chose dire ça peut être même parfois
être très anecdotique mais je sens
toujours qu'il ya une mise sous pression
qui pèse que nécessaire en tout cas qui
est conditionnel vous avez raté les
séquences d'égérie jaune qui a pris
beaucoup de temps suivent eux qui
étaient peut-être elle par contre plus
plus justifiée de meilleur aloi
on en parlera peut-être parlons
justement de ce feuilleton théorique
vous rappeler dans ses livres il y en a
trois déjà sorti mais y en aura d'autre
que l'économie n'a pas toujours voulu
dire ce qu'on ce qu'elle veut dire haut
d'aujourd'hui
l'ours tqm l'économie avant que ça
devienne la comptabilité les marchés et
pas c'était un oui c'était surtout c'est
ce n'est surtout pas une chose quoi sert
il s'agit pas de dire par l'économie
c'est ceci plutôt que cela l'économie a
d'abord été un terme partage est
partagée par des disciplines partagé par
des auteurs partagé par des cultures
aussi par des époques dans notre
tradition occidentale
j'essaie effectivement de rappeler que
le mot économie à exister en théologie
dans les sciences de la nature en
esthétique en métapsychologie en
mathématiques en droit en linguistique
en philosophie le mot et c'est ce que je
marque là le mot a eu droit à des usages
particuliers dans tous ces chants la
rend donc en théologie on a parlé
d'économie la fois on va en parler oui
tout à fait dans les sciences de la
nature l'économie de la nature en
psychanalyse on a parlé d' économie
psychique en biologie on a parlé de
l'économie animal par exemple comment
les organes qu'opère bon pour grey et du
vivant et et bon an mal an permettent à
un organisme de tenir bon et ainsi de
suite
et en fait ce qui m'intéresse c'est deux
choses d'abord le fait que tous ces
usages de évidemment ne sont pas
synonymes hic ce ne sont pas des
synonymes comme freud parle d'économie
psyché qui ne pense pas la même chose
que lorsque les théologies parle du
commerce avec les dieux et l'économie
trinitaires cependant c'est suzanne me
semble-t-il ne peuvent pas être
considérés comme des antonymes cette
époque de simples de simples
coïncidences quoi si on utilise le même
mot c'est qu'il ya bien quelque chose de
transversale à tous ses usagers à bien
le sens commun que j'ai c'est de dégager
est ce que je propose comme définition
qui est amendable
il s'agit pas de figer une fois pour
toutes le sens je remarque à chaque
occurrence économie renvoie à une
connaissance des relations bonnes à une
pensée des relations escomptés ou à la
manifestation ou dans le cas par exemple
des sciences de la nature de leur
relation qui sont bonnes
peut-être dans un sens spinosi ce qu'au
fond au sens où ce qui est bon et ce qui
permet de durer et de durée car en fait
les relations avaient déjà au rang
on aborderait les choses d'un point de
vue esthétique et à quel moment est ce
que l'économie était confisquée par les
économistes
durant le dernier tiers du xviiie siècle
pour être schématique à être plus
complexe à lire dans les nuances mais
d'une manière donc fondamental et nette
à la fin du xviiie siècle les premiers à
se présenter comme étant économistes et
que la postérité va nommer physiocrates
sont des médecins notamment aider
d'aider des gens de la cour de louis 15
influents qui s'inspire beaucoup de
l'économie de la nature des sciences de
la nature pour penser l'agriculture sur
un mode très efficace en s'inspirant de
la physique on est au siècle des
lumières en subordonnant la nature à la
raison et en essayant prétendait-il en
d'accomplir le dessin de la nature grâce
à l'entendement humain
bon c'est un changement de concept tout
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'avant que
les premiers économistes parlent
d'économie comme on le fait maintenant
c'est être en intendance en associant
étendant ses économies avant que cela ne
devienne l'économie de la nature renvoyé
à ce qu'on appelle l'écologie
aujourd'hui dans ce monde n'existait pas
avant dix économies de la nature pour
désigner non pas non pas seulement la
taxinomie des espèces c'est à dire le
classement des espèces mais
l'organisation des espèces dans des
ensembles dans des tours ou vu du climat
des saisons par rapport à des
agencements infinie et jusque chez
charles darwin et après fairfield
osbourne au milieu du xxème siècle sera
encore question de l'économie de la
nature ccc penser l'économie au titre
d'une observation des rapports dans des
écosystèmes permettant aux écosystèmes
de perdurer dans la précarité
quand il y as économies dans ce sens
qu'il n'est pas celui des économistes
aujourd'hui quand les économies il ya
nécessairement une pensée quant à des
différents objets d'agencement de
relations de mise en rapport en tant qu
il n'est que ces relations ne sont pas
soumises à une systématicité ya pas une
comme une sorte de système mécanique qui
une fois pour toutes va faire en sorte
chaque chaque causes produisent les
mêmes effets ou chaque rapport dégage
même résultat il y à cette idée que bon
an mal an le régime de rapports perdure
bien que ce soit dans une sorte d'
incertitude dans dans un fait précaire
pour apeurer cc c'est le cas des
écosystèmes alors l'économie de la
nature c'est votre le premier livre qui
qui de ce feuilleton théorie que vous
lancez aujourd'hui on ne parlerait pas
d'écologie aujourd'hui on parlerait
encore d'économie de la nature qu'est ce
que ça changerait lennon était resté
l'économie de la nature on ne verrait
pas double les mots écologie et économie
nous font voir double alors qu'il s'agit
d'un même phénomène
les écologistes ignorent peut-être enfin
ceux où ce que les écologistes tout
citoyen qui a souci un égard à
l'évolution de nos écosystèmes tout tout
tout citoyen de ce type ignorent
peut-être que le mot économie profit du
chantre de ce qu'on appelle l'écologie
aujourd'hui donc carl von linné au
milieu du xviiie siècle suivi très
rapidement de gueumbeul trois aides en
angleterre line était ce les doigts
réfléchissez en termes d'économies de la
nature des jeux cette expression là on
peut la retrouver au xviie siècle et on
se demandait par exemple comment il se
faisait que cela tiens c'était le
miracle qui veut que pond pas parce que
les vaches ont chaud et vont dans le
marais sera fléchir allant dans le
marais se rafraîchir bancs et des faits
que des vagues et nourrissent des ddd
des microbes des insectes qui eux-mêmes
nourrissent les poissons mais tout ça
est assez fragile bon et darwin va
pousser à bout
le fait cette précarité en dire mais
l'économie de la nature c'est au fond
l'étude de relation des espèces dans sur
fond d'incertitudes
vous donnez un très bon exemple c'est
quand on a réintroduit les loups dont le
parc de yellowstone aux états unis et à
calvillo décennies il ya une vraie
introduit quelques loups première
conséquence ya moins de serre d'abord ce
qui en a quelques-uns qui se font
bouffer pas les loups et puis sinon et
évidemment il se retire il voit un peu
plus loin pour laisser les loups ou loue
la vallée les bords de la rivière et ça
va tout changer mais les paiements se
remettent à pousser oiseaux exactement
les armes deviennent beaucoup plus haut
que nous permet d'ailleurs de remettre
peut-être un petit peu les points sur
les i en ce qui concerne charles darwin
parce que c'est win a eu de très mauvais
lecteurs et moi le cdh ministre rondes
et des ultra libéraux qui ont vu chez
lui où une chanteuse caution à une
théorie d'elliott et de la hiérarchie
universel dédiera c'est la loi du sport
voilà exactement alors qu'est-ce qui est
ce qui est intéressant chez darwin c'est
qu'ils montrent qu'une espèce le bride
que tout toutes les hiérarchies est
occupante au trait à des ensembles qui
sont mouvantes qui sont changeants qui
sont précaires et il suffit qu'une
espèce de lune un peu trop fort pour
tenir à elle-même dans ce cas là les
serres était tellement sûr non mais t'es
tellement puissant qu'il se nuisent est
il détruisait le le site dont il avait
besoin pour persister et donc c'est là
que des de réintroduire contenait la
ville à moins de l'idée d'introduire en
famille une famille de loup a tout
changé même y compris le lait la nature
des cours d'eau le lac des castors qui
sont revenus au fait des barrages et
xorret le plus peur dessert donc ils
sont résolus ccc cela l'économie et mon
travail mon au delà d'un travail
d'érudition consiste à rappeler que le
mot économie en tant que l'on peut en
dégager un concept général à partir de
différents usages dans les sciences de
la nature en esthétique en théologie en
linguistique instruite permet de faire
subir une halte critique à l'usagé
récurrent du mot économie parce qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir d'économie c'est le
résultat n'est pas bon aujourd'hui on
est dans un monde où économie
étape assez rapidement synonyme de
capitalisme de destruction ou de belles
à part donc d'un régime qui est
destructeur inique jeudi reçues source
de beaucoup d'inégalités sociales grands
hits et les choses à grande échelle sur
tout et impérialiste on va parler
méthode par le vocabulaire par
l'accrochant néons et si on était dans
un pays du sud ont selon le verrez tout
de suite donc qu'il y avait quelque
chose d'étrange et qui vient s'imposer
comme un mode pourquoi le pays du sud
leeuwin hémisphère sud de le oui c'est
ce que je vais dire son sont plus vives
ils ont quand on a eu la banque mondiale
le fonds monétaire international au
visage pendant quelques décennies
précédé de puissance coloniale précis de
bon on a eu une série de donneurs de
leçons qui nous devons expliquer comment
on gère une économie justement face à
des gens qui pourtant savent très bien
pensé les relations et aurait pu le
faire de manière beaucoup plus peut-être
fils en tout cas spécifiques
si on les avait laissés en paix mais
aujourd'hui c'est que pour ce ce que
vous dites c'est que pour soutenir notre
mode de vie on est obligé d'hypothéquer
quasiment notre habitat naturel
ça c'est contraire à l'économie au sens
ancien du terme
oui en fait moi parce que je reviendrai
quand même mais seulement la double
appellation économie écologie ainsi le
problème avec l'existant ces deux mots
là ayant oublié que le mont économie
renvoie d'abord à l'économie de la
nature sait qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
d'économie si elle n'est pas écologique
comme on dit aujourd'hui ça ne se peut
pas donc l'idée qu'il faut réconcilier
les deux termes et est une fausse
question c'est à dire que s'il n'ya pas
écologiste il n'y a pas d'économies est
lé usage d'économies que de dumont
économie tel qu'il est fait aujourd'hui
par des experts patentés qui se
prétendent économistes bon encore depuis
deux siècles consiste à
consiste en un usage orwelliens du mois
économie c'est-à-dire qu'on présente
comme étant économique
des opérations qui nuisent à des
habitats naturels à adé à des richesses
des ressources qui le problème de
l'équipe l'économie quand on vous lisent
lesquels le poème de l'économie quand on
vous lit blé l'économie dans son
acception actuelle c'est qu'elle n'est
que de mise rien c'est j'avais déjà dit
qu'elle fait l'économie de la haine
c'est à dire qu'elle haïssant qu'elles
n'y paraissent alors que par les
colonnes comptable par les formes
extérieures par des théories par les
cours de la bourse par toutes sortes de
méthodes on me décale considérablement
le donneur d'ordre qui est dans son jet
privé qui est l étage supérieur d'une
tour à bureaux qui est dans un gala qui
est loin et haut est myope
du coup on le distance des effets sur le
terrain
qu'est ce qu'il en coûte pour une
population pour un écosystème ans pour
que la valeur d'une action augmente à la
bourse on fait l'économie de d'une forme
de haine qui est en jeu parce que très
souvent on se subordonnent les
populations ont les 8 10 et même dans
les états occidentaux qui prétendent à
une certaine richesse on rend les gens
fous on en avait parlé à l'époque de la
médiocratie je regrettais des
psychotropes c'est l'alcool c'est la
télé c est aller tout ce qu'on est pas
ici il faut que je fasse cette critique
s'y met c'est tout ce dont on se gave
ont sans parler des bords dans des
dépressions parce qu'on est dans un
système qui est pétri de haine de mépris
d'indifférence parce que tout ce qui
compte c'est les colonnes comptable et
ont ni soumis aux colonnes comptable on
fait des économies au fond de la pensée
on fait l'économie de la sensibilité on
fait l'économie de tout ce qui nous
permettrait de voir que ce régime nous
fait souffrir et y compris ceux qui en
profitent à un titre ou à un autre
jusqu'à ceux qui le subissent de plein
fouet
étant donné ses pratiques et ses modes
d'expression cela de nous
est ce qu'on aurait pu se développer
autrement j'entends par se développer
gagner en confort et augmenter notre
démographie les êtres humains il a fallu
pour cela
effectivement alors est-ce qu'on a obéi
à l'économie de la nature à ce moment là
pour parvenir à l'heure où est-ce qu'on
a obéi à cette image là qui n'a rien à
voir avec l'économie de la nature celle
qui viennent d'apparaître derrière vous
et moi c'est le salon de l'agriculture
c'est le contraire de l'économie de la
nature dans l'impression quand on vous
lit
c'est un rationnement à courte vue mais
il est entendu que lorsque on coupe à
blanc des forêts lorsqu'on crée des
porcheries industrielles qui ne pollue
massivement les nappes phréatiques
lorsque on vide les océans de leurs
poissons
lorsqu'on fait disparaître des espèces
mais massivement d'une manière en tout
cas programmée aujourd'hui
lorsqu on transforme l'atmosphère d'une
poubelle
lorsqu'on rend lorsqu'on scie la branche
sur laquelle on est assis et sur
laquelle se trouve face il y à peu près
tout ce qu'on a rendu dépendant de soi
il ya entendu qu'on peut pas qualifier
d' économique une approche du genre donc
effectivement le dial ya sans doute que
notre régime carnivore et dévastateur et
un économiste qui s'appelle georgescu
nicholas de nicholas georgescu roegen
c'est un américano humain qui a parlé
d'entropie nous produisons du déchet
nous êtres humains plus que les animaux
d'ailleurs ce qui fait de nous des
sujets - enfin sauf que l'économie de la
nature que d'autres parce que
contrairement à la plupart des espèces
et même à toutes les autres espèces
nous nous chauffons à partir de sources
énergétiques et nous chauffons nos
aliments et nous construisons à
répétition et de manière de plus en plus
sophistiquées des instruments ans
contrairement aux autres espèces et donc
nous détruisons nous créons de
l'entropie c'est-à-dire de l'énergie
comme ça inutilisable et encombrantes
que ce soit un plan atmosphérique ou sur
le plan d'aidé des objets des sols ainsi
de suite et nous rendons la planète à
terme
inhabitat que fera peut-être ma vision
aurions nous pu faire autrement
mounir doit de rester des tribus ils ne
font civ à la merci des gros mammifères
mais je ne dirais pas d'une manière
aussi péjorative mais quelque chose du
genre
c'est à dire être frugaux à tout le
moins être mesuré pas comprendre ce qui
implique des décisions qui consiste par
exemple à doter à peu près chaque
citoyen d'une automobile à rendre
l'automobile indispensable a présenté un
régime carnivore comme étant tout à fait
le convenable est normal diront dire on
en a on a on a hissé au rang des
standards du besoin ou voire du droit
d'y pratiquer qui dont on n'a pas le
luxe quand on n'a pas le luxe si on est
économe si on est économe écrit moi ce
qui m'importe beaucoup dans ce travail
c'est vraiment de
de marquer ceci je m'adresse à mes
contemporains sinon on ne serait pas là
tous les deux mais par rapport à un
monde qui ne nous est pas contemporaine
parce que ce mode économie telle qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui renvoi des
conditions de possibilité qui ne seront
pas au rendez-vous longtemps on est dans
un monde dont la crise climatique est
proprement effrayant la biodiversité est
menacée ou à un point tel que la chaîne
alimentaire universelle va s'en trouver
perturbée à terme l'énergie abondante et
abordable connaît aussi ses derniers ces
dernières années d'être la dernière
décennie même chose pour les jeunes ça
fait longtemps qu'on lui dit oui oui
mais mais on en est à chercher du
pétrole à 3000 mètres sous les eaux dans
de la boue en alberta je veux dire on
est en plus de dix ans racle les fonds
de tiroirs l'avons l'a6 et n'intéressait
personne ya 20 ou 30 ans donc on
retrouve encore des méthodes polluantes
pour arriver à des à satisfaire une
certaine demande mais on voit bien qu'on
arrive si on a un petit peu le sens de
l'histoire
au regard des choses en plus sur le
temps long même à moyen terme
on voit bien content qu'on arrive au
terme de quelques choses le mot économie
ne pourra pas signifier longtemps ce
qu'il signifie aujourd'hui et il faudra
le redéfinir et mon travail est plus un
travail d'anticipation quoi savoir qu'il
y aura un moment où il faudra repenser
l'économie qu'en mettant le une façon
multiple de réfléchir aux relations qui
nous sont bonnes alors le deuxième
volume de ce feuilleton théorique
portent sur l'économie de la foi alors
c'est quoi l'économie de la fois pour
vous enfin pas pour vous qu'est ce que
c'était qu'est ce que c'est en soi ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir la
présence l'existence de mon économie
dans des textes variés dans une cité
variés en ce qui concerne l'économie de
la foi c'est tout simplement le nouveau
testament dans les épîtres de paul il y
à quelques reprises
le mot économie qui paraît chez les
pères de l'église les premiers
théologien lipolytiques rennais
tertullien quand on développe
particulièrement le concède la trinité
le mot économie centrale il désigne
toutes sortes chose il peut désigner le
ventre de marie jésus-christ le plan de
la rédemption c'est un bout quitte la
trinité dans la chambre trinité
elle-même s'était c'est un mot
polysémique qui embarrasse beaucoup les
traducteurs et c'est ce qui fait que on
ne retrouve pas un quand on lit des
traductions de ce qui est le plus
souvent le cas de ces textes
l'expression économie et c'est grâce à
giorgio agamben où marie-josé mondzain
qui ont été d'assises à cause de votre
place il ya très peu de temps à qui je
dois beaucoup sur ce quant à cet
opuscule c'est grâce à la restitution
qu'ils ont fait de ce mot dans les
textes qui cite que j'ai pu en repérer
beaucoup d' usage est en fait qu'est ce
que c'est pour aller vite
l'économie c'est l'idée qu'il y a un
rapport à penser à établir entre le plan
des concepts et le plan sensible le la
matérialité
ça peut sembler très étrange et à nous
mais on le vit tous les jours lorsqu'on
dit non éborgné des manifestants et leur
arracher la mer c'est indigne d'un état
de droit par exemple eh bien l'on met en
rapport
une situation où il ya un état et sa
police ses décideurs qui on l'espère ou
autorisent ou commande un peu flou des
actes est un principe et l'économie
c'est le rapport entre l'un et l'autre à
savoir que l'un ne peut pas exister sans
l'autre
c'est à dire qu'un concept tout seul
sans matérialisation sensible ici ou là
dans l'histoire est un fantasme c'est à
dire que si on n'est qu'un concept mais
on ne cultive que lui pour lui même
on est illuminée on verse dans un bar
abstraites des choses strictement
exclusivement sans procès pendant risque
le nihilisme la débandade le chaos
au sens le plus péjoratif qui soit et
l'économie de la fois c'est de penser le
rapport entre les deux ans j'ai en tête
un concept il est une référence
abstraite que je considère comme tel
l'autre une abstraction qui ne
s'incarnera jamais comme tel mais il y a
dans l'histoire des formes qui lui
ressemble qui s'en réclament
et en théologie c'était le rapport entre
le père le fils et le saint-esprit telle
église aussi l'elysée ait légué la
traduction terrestres ce qu'il ya une
église derrière vous il pourrait y avoir
une mosquée derrière vous ce sera la
même chose tu as fait ça fonctionne en
fait de la même manière on pourrait
mettre une mairie tout c'est la même
chose si ou à châteaufort puisque une
université la grâce il est prince ont
vécu dans des châteaux forts
il se réclame et driout se réclamer du
roi la mairie se réclament de la
république de la liberté de l'égalité de
la fraternité
tout ça ça fonctionne pareil pour vous
c'est de l'économie de la fois c'est une
equi dans le sens où on jette son dévolu
sur un principe on a foi en un principe
même qu'on immanentiste ya un principe
identique qui paradoxalement il est
situé le royaume la réédition refrain
strictement la figure du père du fils et
que le fils sans la caution du père et
qu'un barbu à gars qui bon délire dans
la cité bon et c'est le père bon la
référence abstraite qui lui confère une
autorité
c'était ce que jésus est le fils de dieu
qui est de dire ce qu'il dit oui et qu
on lui accordera
une conscience dire une attention et une
crédibilité
mais inversement on s'il n'est pas là on
n'a pas accès à dieu lorsqu'il s'est
trop abstrait c'est trop lointain cci le
verbe n'est pas dans une langue qu'on
parle ne se manifeste pas bon donc donc
on attend les pères de l'église on
penser l'économie de la fois ainsi c'est
effectivement le fils ensuite le fils on
le voit pas non plus le fait c'est les
sculptures quand on a dans les églises
que quand qu'on voyait ce sont les
peines les tableaux les vitraux ensuite
c'est toute une histoire ce sont des
comptes c'est ce qui fait les livres
dits sacrés mais le même processus
contient autant chez les anarchistes ou
où nous le château fort avec la
féodalité le rapport à et au roi et à
dieu ou à l'empereur
tout cela tient à la il y as économies
quand il ya la pensée d'un rapport entre
les deux c'est à dire que si on n'est
que dans la dévotion on perd de vue
au fond le lui dire ça on bascule et on
est bon il ya quelque chose qui est pas
économique dans le sens où la
circulation ne se fait plus et de même
les formes occupante qui qui meublent
notre vie sociale se réclame de principe
est ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
chez les théologiens humaine comment le
mot économie a eu son évolution et a
fini par trouver moment par désigner
aussi et c'est sa part son bras pas je
suis pas ici non plus beau plaider pour
l'économie comme si c'était une cause
mais quand c majuscule mois us à
personne parce que par économie enseigné
à mentir et économie vous là où city
recevra l'économie de la fois il ya des
choses dans la bible qui sont absolument
et étrangère au contraire à ce que
préconise rond ou postuleront les dix
commandements bon donc
donc on fait une religion rodez sans
cesse des scènes de colère divine 6,8
donc il faudra les justifier on va les
justifier par économie donc on va mentir
on voit rafistolé on va tricher avec la
vérité mais au profit d'un principe
supérieur à ces anomalies ou ses frais
sans fil continue de faire ça
aujourd'hui tous les jours et perd on
agit grand et beau parent est content de
ce point de vue là mais c'est un
problème parce que dire quand on se
présente comme le prêtre le chef de
l'état l'élu
l'élu dans tous les sens le
le désigner bon on se réclame en vertu
de quelque chose qui présentait comme
venant avant c'est je ne suis pas là
pour manifester un pouvoir qui serait le
mieux je fais simplement traduire une
force une autorité qui met plus grande
qui kim excède quoi et qui nous excède
et j'en suis simplement le traducteur
mais quand on dit ça on instaure la
chose on se présente comme recevant son
autorité en même temps qu'on la fonde et
ça suppose énormément de responsabilités
et quand on n'est pas économique dans un
sens souhaitable on abuse ce pouvoir-là
dire ou non au nom de ceux dont je
m'autorise un jeu je peux commettre en
fait de beaucoup de forfaits bon et la
pensée économique et les potes du tout
la sainte cène le dire quoi dire c'est
pas réglé on s'est pas une chose qui une
fois pour toutes ce c'est pas quelque
chose que je célèbre mais il reste dans
l'histoire on a on a beaucoup fait rayer
avec ça parce que c'est un problème
l'économie de la foi dans ce sens là et
j'apprécie beaucoup les écrits là dessus
d'un penseur de l'école de francfort qui
est riche from qui en vient à dire alors
les marxistes qui va emmener dans tout
autre chose mais il réfléchit à la fois
mini la fois c'est vraiment le la fois
désigne cette façon qu'on a de se donner
des principes qui sont pas trop éthérée
et qui ne sont pas trop éloignés
c'est un principe qui n'est pas
nécessairement que à l'oeuvre ça peut
être un principe qui renvoie à quelque
chose à faire comme la révolution mais
un principe qui renvoie à une pratique
faisable et souhaitable donc quand on a
la foi dans le sens des riches comme
tout de suite on est à l'oeuvre cette
fois l'hôte doit nous amener à agir en
fonction de ce en quoi on croit par
rapport à la crise climatique par
exemple une fois qu'ils seraient de
mauvais aloi sa red deer bras dieu va
tout régler
sauf si on est dans la transcende ordres
radio va tout régler si on est en liman
envoie les scientifiques vont tout
régler mais l'on reste pas c'est parce
qu'on a une sorte de foi paresseuse et
lui militer pour une fois vont active
c'est-à-dire croire en des principes qui
quels qu'ils soient là je suis pas en
train de l'est
les dicter un kiki dont le signe de leur
pertinence et qu'ils nous font agir on
s'interrompt fait une pause et on
reprend tout de suite après avec alain
deneault
[Musique]
le pire je pense en tout cas
politiquement pour l'union européenne
c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
anglais il y aura peut-être un effet
boule de neige si l'italie sort vous
avez un éclatement de l'euro et de
l'union européenne dans les mois qui
suivent
l'euro s'est pas seulement un projet
financier c'est un projet politique au
smic
l'euro ne fonctionne pas sinon on
n'aurait pas eu ce gros elle a lu avec
nos graisses je suis passé n'ont pas
d'accord sur l'échec de l'euro ou
maintient la grèce en commun à mon avis
une bonne chose vous pouvez pas vous
réjouir d'avoir pays qui est sous
perfusion sous assistance respiratoire
en permanence
haifa j'ai entendu parler de wikileaks
et de julian assange pour la première
fois quand j'ai vu les images filmées
depuis l'hélicoptère en irak a tiré et
je pense qu'il ya des gens dans l'armée
américaine qui ne lui ont jamais
pardonné
je ne sais pas pour la peine de mort et
puisque je ne suis pas pour la peine de
mort il n'a qu'une chose à faire abattre
ce fils de qui légalement et est
historique d'avoir un journaliste
indépendant
un type avec son ordinateur révélant des
crimes de guerre un large public
l'idée de développer une boîte de dépôts
numériques anonyme en lien avec le média
qu'est wikileaks
c'est une vraie nouveauté mais je
n'avais pas prévu qu'il deviendra
célèbre dans le monde entier si vite
qu'il serait à la tête de l'une des plus
puissantes organisations médiatiques du
monde à vaches
à il avait beaucoup de jalousie dans
l'ue et médias traditionnels en verre
wikileaks est en vert assange en
particulier pourquoi n'est-il pas plus
comme donc ils l'ont accusée d' étaler
des excréments sur les murs morose ce
qui est fou
et du roller julian assange est à l'
isolement dans une prison de haute
sécurité attendant peut-être une
sentence d'emprisonnement à perpétuité
alors je ne veux pas le voir mourir dans
une prison américaine à l'infini et je
crois que c'est le sort qui l'attend
on a de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont atteints d'obésité on a de plus en
plus d'enfants qui sont baisse de plus
en plus tôt l'obésité génère 18 autres
maladies derrière apnées du sommeil
diabète cancer l'hypertension artérielle
en fertilité hommes et femmes
moi ce que je vois c'est ce que ça coûte
aux individus en terme psychologique en
terme médical en termes sociétale en
termes professionnels et ça ça fait des
dégâts considérables
ce qui est fait en france par an chose
pour pas dire rien ça ne se soigne pas à
coup de spots télé ça ne se soigne pas à
coups de livres ça se soigne avec des
véritables médecin tout ce qui peut être
fait c'est pas moi je peux passer en
2004 c'est faux ça commence chez soi
tout de suite maintenant
[Musique]
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec le
philosophe alain deneault qui s'est
lancé dans un feuilleton théorique en
publiant à la suite trois livres le
premier l'économie de la nature
le deuxième l'économie de la foi et le
troisième l'économie esthétique
nous étions en train de parler de
l'économie de la fois c'est notre
matrice institutionnels expliquez-vous
alain deneault dans ce livre d'abord
religieuse plus politique
au fond c'est tout ce qui relève d'un
principe supérieur et aujourd'hui encore
dit vous il ne saurait y avoir
d'administration sans en référer un
principe supérieur liée à un fait
croyance que ce soit l'idée que l'on se
fait de la république là c'est typique
on a une croyance dans la république
mais on pourrait dire quand on regarde à
paris le ministère des finances bercy
comme on l'appelle avec cette forme très
particulière qui rappelle l'époque où on
passait sous un porche comme ça et que
l'on était obligé de payer la gabelle
la sla ya une croyance supérieure pour
accepter de payer nos impôts
chaque bois que ce soit vous canadien où
nous français il faut qu'il y ait une
croyance effectivement il ya un principe
qui est à l'oeuvre c'est ce principe
n'est pas nécessairement un carnet dans
l'architecturé c'est évidemment une
façon commode de l'image et mais c'est
peut-être un principe abstrait tout
simplement une idée une idée qu'on
cultive mais cette idée il ne sera
cultivé que si des formes l'incarnent et
nous renvoie à l'idée parfois par de
demain par négation par opposition on va
dire à ce n'est pas juste
ne serait-ce que cette phrase très
courante ce n'est pas juste qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire voilà
j'aimerais faire un concept de la
justice ou une idée de la justice comme
je me fais et je mesure à londres cette
définition que je me donne ce qu'il en
est dans le cas mais dans l'eau parce
que vous parler de justice quand on voit
le nouveau palais de justice à paris qui
est une otan le bercy on l'a vu nous
rappelle quelque chose le passage sous
l'octroi autant le nouveau palais de
justice n'y a plus aucune référence à
l'idée à ce principe supérieur que nous
faisons de la justice l'idée de la
balance l'idée de l'égalité de tous ça a
disparu dans cette dans cette
architecture qui au fond c'est à palais
de justice ça pourrait être n'importe
quoi d'autre il ya quand même une
verticalité canton je vois la photo en
contre-plongée je me sens jugé d'une
certaine façon je vous dise que quelque
chose comme ça est à l'oeuvre
je crois peut-être je jure je mets dans
la peau de ceux qui ont conçu le projet
et de ce qu'ils ont à prouver qu'on veut
peut-être modifier les symboles
présenter la justice aujourd'hui comme
étant peut-être plus technique
peut-être qu'on veut dissocier le droit
de la justice ce qui serait peut-être
marque d'honnêteté
même si on peut le regretter quant au
fond à savoir qu'aujourd'hui le droit
administre offrons des permissions
administre les litiges des contrats des
cours du contrat mais sur un mode où au
moins - économique que jadis
- liées justement un principe parce que
on finit par les perdre de vue ses
principes
d'autant plus qu'on est dans un monde
managériales dit qu'effectivement sombre
dans l'individualité des rapports si je
vous suis bien l'économie tels que vous
ne les décrivez dans son acception
ancien qui était si varié ça consiste à
chaque fois on une pensée une pratique
qui met en relation au fond d'eux ordre
différent c'est ça peut-être pas de deux
ordres c'est le cas de l'économie de la
foi mais des éléments s'est très vite
une définition très large évidemment
parce qu'il s'agit d' ensuite de
s'intéresser à des cas et mon travail
consiste à développer une thèse majeur
qui quiconque ce qui relève de ce
concept en étudiant des détails mineurs
c'est à dire des occurrences en ce qui
concerne le l'économie de la fois par
exemple c'est ce qui c'est intéressant
de voir que chez un blaise pascal par
exemple on finit par en parler de mer
très confiant parce que l'économie comme
je le mentionnais plus tôt désigne aussi
une façon de convaincre de persuader
peut-être de tromper et pascal regrette
cette époque où le roi peut faire peur
simplement
invoquant des limites des figures des
objets de croyance supérieure et il ya
des passages formidable dans les pensées
ou il dira des revenants explicitement à
cette économie où justement on va on va
ordonner les choses simplement parce
qu'on se réclame d'une force qui est qui
qui terrifie ou qui impressionne la
république qui est juste derrière vous
et derrière moi et de nous terrifie pas
néanmoins c'est une ruse si l'on vous
comprend bien
voici 6 6 et en son nom qu'on nous
envoie des crs peut-être oui ils ont
l'agent du fisc ou cours à la limite on
a besoin de nous envoyer la largeur du
fisc et parfois les crs à ce que la
société continue de fonctionner ce sera
au nom d'un prêt ses preuves du nil
blanc où c'est plus grave encore c'est
quand on nous envoie dans les tranchées
pendant quatre ans 1914
tous les soldats les poilus défendre la
patrie la république
ça va faire un million et demi de morts
rien que chez les français oui on se
fait masser un discours en fait
qu'est-ce qui s'impose et qui qui
constitue là à ce moment là une
rhétorique d'état oui tout à fait on
dirait que les pays comme la france
c'est un mythe pour vous dans l'économie
de la fois c'est un mythe au fond qui se
traduit par par des douaniers par des
policiers par des soldats on les a vus
là mais au fond c'est un mythe
ça n'existe pas mais oui c'est c'est
plutôt ça une traduction terrestre oui
est réelle mais c'est un mythe au départ
c'est un mythe au départ quand on lit ce
qu'il en est de l'économie de manière
rudimentaire chez dans les épîtres de
paul l'économie renvoie plutôt à une
administration c'est à dire qu'il ya un
mythe qui est très puissant qui est puis
qui offre qui celui de la parole de dieu
la l'instance divine et qui ordonne à
des fidèles de créer des églises et on a
un rapport très rudimentaire de
l'économie sur un mode unilatérale il ya
la puissance la source du pouvoir est la
source de toutes choses qui enjoint des
économes c'est comme ça qu'ils sont
désignés dans ses lettres à créer des
églises dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles dans l'empiré romain
ensuite devant rusé quand contre des des
m'écrire des
des profanes des bons on doit trouver
des tactiques les procédés pour rendre
le discours référentiel en l'occurrence
dieu le dieu des chrétiens mais on
pourrait décliner les choses autrement
d'une manière parlante et donc la figure
du fils devient de plus en plus
importante parce que elle est en quelque
sorte elle et elle est visible elle est
audible elle incarne quelque chose de
moi beaucoup plus nets ont dit on vous
comprenez peut-être pas dieu parce
qu'effectivement c'est loin c'est
abstrait faisons je vous demandais
vraiment qu'ils ont nés pour nous
réclamer de cette chose mais il ya le
fils bon il ya des églises
il ya des comptes il ya des histoires il
ya des couleurs et il ya des rituels etc
par ses formes là qu'on veut donner de
la consistance au principe mais la
république française fonctionne
exactement comme ça effectivement et
c'est ce à quoi elle vise et vous aurez
par exemple un clic et non par exemple
très nostalgique de l'époque où ça
fonctionne et au quart de tour aux
embolie voudrait même qu'on légiférer
s'ils pouvaient 1 pour qu'on revienne à
sa dans ce qui m'apparaît est un
fantasme politique quoi mais évidemment
c'est ton d état de grâce qui se
commande pas mais les économies de la
fois réfléchi à ce rapport qui lie à
entre les incarnations sensible d'une
chose qu'on ne voit pas et la chose
qu'on ne voit pas en tant qu elle et
persuasive sur le régime de
l'entendement et du symbole est
effectivement des abstractions et donc
moi je me suis pas intéressé plus dure
au delà de ce que je cerne à cette
question sinon je reviens à ma thèse
majeur pour rappeler que le mot économie
a existé de diverses façons
et pas seulement de la façon dont ce qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui est aussi
pour montrer une deuxième chose c'est
que les sciences économiques
et là je vais mettre côté des gens plus
critiques qu'ils agissent à la marge et
qui sont des amis mais politiquement
mais je pense que toute une série
d'idéologues il me semble majoritaire
dans ce domaine et qui déguisent
il au fond des discours d'intérêt en
sciences et qui skie m'a intéressé chez
eux en particulier c'est de voir que
toutes ses économies régionales en
esthétique psychique biologiques
écologiques ainsi deux sites se trouvent
récupérer dans leur sphère est
restreinte à un certain nombre
d'intérêts c'est à dire que dans le
discours
la science économique telle qu'on
l'entend couramment il y aura des
références à la psychologie
continuellement le moral des ménages
l'humeur des marchés est beaucoup dans
le management
la psychologie au travail trouvé ça
sympa d'aller travailler avoir un chief
à béni saf essieux qui va s'assurer
qu'on soit joyeux ain
pendant qu on performe bon il y aura
toute cette économie psychique à
l'oeuvre mais sur un mode instrumental
pas sur un mode s'ouvre un an comme
l'économie de ses pensées autrement il y
aura la même chose par rapport
évidemment aux écosystèmes j'ai parlé de
l'agriculture tout à l'heure de la façon
dont on a ramené l'agriculture dans le
champ de la performativité quoi alors
qu'elle renvoyait une sorte de spectacle
saisissant pour ce qu'il étudiait au
départ et par rapport à la théologie
c'est à dire que là on usera des
procédés théologique pour rendre viable
des marques des produits peut-être aussi
des figures il se sera exactement la
même chose et j'ai été stupéfait de voir
il ya quelques années un livre qui
s'intitule encore prête
j'étais sûr que c'est un ouvrage
critique qui consistait à dire au
deuxième degré voilà les entreprises
comportent comme des religions ces deux
nouvelles églises nous
belle mosquée oumm et ce sont elles
aujourd'hui qui abondent régissent le
commun pense le lien ainsi dit non
c'était au premier degré c'était de très
sérieux professeur de management qui
expliquait que la marque doit apparaître
ou auprès de ses consommateurs mais
aussi auprès des employés qui sont liés
en la marque de l'entreprise comme un
objet salvat tic comme une cause et donc
on cite vous les imaginez tout de suite
d une marque de stylos des marques de
mode choisis des marques de jeux de
chaussures de sport par exemple marque
de baskets qui parmi les trois plus plus
célèbres avec l'heureux avec leur slogan
qui est une sorte de 2 voilà deux
religieux de l'île où les devises
oui ça de profession fois quasiment
exactement et des plus cons ce qui est
intéressant par dans votre votre choix
justement c'est d'avoir des marques sont
le produit parce que la marque se suffit
à elle-même elle devient la cause
à la rigueur elle pourrait pratiquement
ne rien nous vendre c'est le but c'est
quand même nous vendre quelque chose au
bout du compte mais mais qu on communie
autour d'elle et cons et qu'on se sent
exister par elle qu'on semble qu'elle
nous investit bon et ça devenir un
un art that's du principe est évidemment
c'est insatisfaisant c'est beaucoup plus
satisfaisant à croire en une marque de
chaussures quand un principe politique
ou spirituelle donc on en a on a brossé
un acte de substitution pour nous
encombrer son plein dès que ça marche
aux 10 il ya quelque chose d'un peu
pathétique quand on voit ces marques
tenter de créer de la mythologie
certaines y parviennent parfois il ya un
engouement il ya un rêve via ses ailes
sont tellement chargé de deux puissances
mais je parle de puissance rêvez pas de
puissance économique
parfois ça marche et d'autres fois on se
dit c'est un peu pitoyable il voudrait
nous faire rêver alors qu'ils nous
vendent de la verroterie je vais
répondre oui non et oui et ça fonctionne
comme ça c'est à dire que dans un
premier temps ça marche c'est à dire
qu'on nous dit on nous dit de nerfs
suggestives par des campagnes
publicitaires par défaut trou par toutes
sortes de procédés on ne dit ta vie vaut
pas grand chose n'a pas vraiment d'amis
bon ta carrière se passe pas comme tu le
voudrais mais une bière une marque de
chaussures une moto pas tous réglés
comme en font cette moto et tu sera la
figure que tu vois cette figure ce sera
toi donc est donc sacré harley davidson
des grands meetings aux états unis où
tous les propriétaires de
deux motocyclettes de cette marque se
rencontrent des communions 1,10 mais ce
bond est évidemment que exercer mon nom
ça ne marche pas c'est parce que parce
qu on est frustré
ça ne marche pas pour toutes les raisons
que depuis longtemps exposé la
psychanalyse de risque oui zen au savoir
que la différence entre le mythe et le
message publicitaire c'est que le mythe
accompagne les sujets quant à la faille
qui sont là leur entente existant en le
mythe nous accompagnent cantaou fait
mais nous sommes déçus j'ai fait deux
failles et nous permet d'accompagner
notre blessure alors que le message
publicitaire d'une manière tout à fait
abusive nous dit je vais rigoler je vais
pas si ton problème et surtout pas pnse1
je vais pas si ton problème et je vais
être au fond une 1h that de solutions
qwam et je me présentais comme la
solution évidemment je vais comme te
sauver je vais te souviens tu de ton
problème c'est à dire moins de biens
avec des amis sur un terrain celle qu'on
va te piquer venir à chaque fois une
moto réceptionnés et tu seras sauvé est
évident ça ne marche pas et qu'est ce
qui se passe on en redemande
et c'est là l'aspect pervers de la chose
on en redemande dans la mesure où parce
que ça nous satisfait pas mais qu on y
prie de devenir l'hymne et dans le
processus commercial
on n'en finit plus de demander à la
chose qu'elle nous donne ce que nous
donne précisément pas ce qui fait qu'on
y revient et c'est pour ça que tout ce
qui tout ce qu'il suppose la
consommation compulsive et qui le plus
souvent procès de ce mécanisme là est le
signe d'un échec mais qui précisément
les chais que des managers cynique
chercha à voir se réaliser
il aimerait bien mettre de la magie là
dedans alors qu'il n'y a que du commerce
vous dit néanmoins que la magie de
moeurs on a eu beau désenchanté le monde
vous la magie de moeurs et je pensais en
vous lisant à ces images qu'on a vus par
les manifestations des gilets jaunes où
on a vu tous ces drapeaux français
s'agiter la cc de la magie quand on
agite d'impôt français c'est parce que
ça nous fait penser à la révolution
parce que ça fait penser à la patrie il
ya quelque chose bien on est des
français comme les autres ne nous
oubliez pas enfin on peut y mettre tout
ce qu'on veut mais surtout et avant tout
de la magie non oui mais oui eh ben oui
son voeu c'est pas un mot que j'utilise
très bien mon jeu l'utilisent maison j j
insiste pas obligé en face à
l'opérationnel jeu je regarderai surtout
pas la chose de ou en tous les cas où de
manière péjorative ou mac
oui bien évidemment nous ne sommes pas
des chiens et nous sommes des êtres de
symboles et ses symboles la doivent à
tout prix nous s'ils sont ils procèdent
mire économique être en quelques
centaines en phase avec une action dont
on se sent parties prenantes
le problème d'un symbole qui serait
vironnement du mental et
dogmatique et vie dure écrasant sais
c'est qu'il nous soumettrait sur le mode
de la stricte obéissance comme j'en
parlais dans sa forme primitive avec
paul où là on a simplement une voix qui
nous dit et kraft ouest souffre créé les
églises les fetwas étriper par les
romains puis voilà ces sites ont
longuement et sinon elles peur de moi
bon et à partir de 3 4e siècle de notre
ère de manière plus subtile on a des
théologiens qui comprenne qu'il doit y
avoir un fait inquiète que l'économie de
la foi et du principe suppose que tandis
que on se réclame d'un principe et qu'on
travaille à l'incarner de collectivement
dans des formes
cette façon de l'incarner cette façon
lui donner corps cette façon de lui
donner des couleurs et une façon
d'écrire ce concept et doit être
participatif c'est à dire quand même
temps qu'on se réclame de lui on le
composent
et c'est là où il ya une circulation il
ya de l'événement il ya de l'évolution
est ce qu'on peut parler d que deux
bidons oui exactement parce qu'il a du
temps et il y adeux ici ici à ipanema du
thym et il ya aussi de jeu c'est un bon
compte dont on abuse mon pour elle a
pour part commandité par l'outil de
liberté une forme de liberté en jeu
qu'elle veut je réponds d'un principe
parce que je suis né dans une société
qui se développe et bien avant moi là à
moins d'être libéral fou on sait quand
on dépend de la culture dépend de
l'histoire bon rythme au besoin de
rappeler ça donc on est dans un guide
constitution se réclame de choses qui
existent à titre de référence dans notre
culture mais en même temps qu'on s'en
réclament
on participe à leur ai dit terry et dans
cette réitération là il ya un jeu et
codes mais qui s'installe et qui ne doit
pas il n'est pas souhaitable qu'il
relève la streak soumission quoi alors
il ya eu trois suspects abus troisième
parution de ce feuilleton théorique
alain deneault l'économie esthétique qui
est devenu dites-vous une composante
essentielle de notre régime alors qu'est
ce que vous entendez par l'économie
esthétique
là aussi c'est un temps que je n'invente
pas que je retrouve mon chez gérard
genette gerland barthes ou dans une
autre mesure chez chez jacques derrida
bon mais par rapport à des usages qui
datent de des changes de lettres autour
de la princesse de clèves où le mot
existe vous parlera par une série d'
usage sur la monnaie du sens ce rebond
est bon une façon de le dire rapidement
c'est le résumé temps page quoi ce site
dire que ces penseurs là on a désigné
économique
la relation entre des éléments d'une
oeuvre pour produire un effet bon ça
peut être un effet strictement
esthétique une sensation tout d'un coup
un peintre par un point blanc suggère un
regard qui lui même est chargée de
signification et donc on va dire ben
voilà procédé économique par peu de
moyens qu'est-ce qu'on dégage du sens et
on suscite des impressions sur un mode
donc profond est chargé l'économie ça
pourrait être sur le plan de la
vraisemblance aussi c'est ce qui nous
intéresse
l'afa sondage ans comme dans le cinéma
noir ou le roman noir la façon d'agencer
des éléments pour arriver à ce qu'un
auteur juge nécessaire on sait que les
essais à intrigues sont écrits à rebours
en vue qui est un crime pour qui un
crime faut quelle arme du crime
motif aussi bon et ben on construit à
rebours pour ensuite donner à la
lectrice lecteur qui entre dans le récit
une sensation de naturel et de nécessité
d'allouer parce qu'il ya eu ceux ci et
là personne s'est retrouvée dans tel
atelier dans l'atelier avec arme du
crime et il était là parce que
évidemment l'autre bon s'en servaient à
tel point et et quand il ya économie
c'est que les choses sont fluides
on n'est pas obligé de s'expliquer sans
s'étend sur la raison de la présence de
l'arme du crime lors il faut que ça soit
fluide où ça sera sur 10 des formes peu
stéréotypé on va dire voilà bien
évidemment un intellectuel il avait des
lunettes vous c'est bien évidemment un
mafieux il buvait du whisky bon voilà il
ya des signes comme ça qu'ils rendent
économique c'est qu'on est très on
comprend qu'ils ont fait face
ensuite il ya des auteurs comme jacques
rancière qui ont montré que l'économie
du récit peut être aussi beaucoup plus
ouverte
on s'est peut-être et auront arraché
chez le présent c'est cette idée que la
la composition ouverte dans un champ
comme ça de possibles de forme peu donné
un peu aléatoire générer quelque chose
donc sera mode comme ça plus distendus
sans qu'on puisse tous permettre vous
quand même encore que la chose une
certaine tenue en doc c'est aussi
l'économie du récit est évidemment
toutes ses formes ont été très utiles au
marketing au management parce que on les
a récupérés pour rendre un grand
vignoble impressionnant des acteurs
qu'on présentait comme géniaux
rationnelle ou méritant alors qu'il
s'agit pour cette esthétique qui
contribue à nous les présente et elle
mais aujourd'hui on pourrait dire qu'il
n'ya peut-être plus d'économies
esthétique au sens où tout est permis
justement tout c'est permis non vous ne
rêvez la télévision se passe dans les
arts même que les conventions les règles
les parfois date draconiennes con
qu'on imposait autrefois pour que ce
soit de l'art pour que ce soit du
théâtre pour ce soit de la peinture tout
ça n'existe plus ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on en est conscient et on se
joue c'est un peu comme les joueurs
d'échecs qui connaissent les entrées qui
connaissent les possibles c'est quand on
se
on se joue maintenant et des formes
économiques dollars on n'est plus soumis
au fonctionnement la com comme si on
était soumis à l'hypnose et iliad rigide
par exemple s'intéresser à cela dans les
faux monnayeurs justement les faux
monnayeurs c'est une oeuvre qui nous
montre comment dire à un romancier vais
écrire un roman sans personnage parce
que ils constituent ils estiment que le
le sing est en crise qu'il ya aucune
forme qui va vont rendre justice avions
et la représentation du réel donc comme
il ya une conscience des formes on se
met à parler d'eux c'est à ce moment là
qu'on se met à parler de son économie ou
où c'est à ce moment qu'on en parle avec
beaucoup de métaphores monétaire avant
de l'amener du sens des monnaies qui
circulent la fausse monnaie
la fausse monnaie qui passe pour la
bonne et ça s'il y avait toute une série
anatole france ce samedi à toute une
série de romans on est dans notre
histoire qui dans la modernité on
renvoie à cette idée d'une monnaie du
sens qui est défaillante qui est une
fausse monnaie bon qui permet de tricher
et le roman s'intéresse beaucoup aux
formes symboliques aussi des qui permet
d'abuser des consciences et à partir du
moment où on en est conscient on en joue
consciemment mais on n'est pas affranchi
de ses formes là on est pas on n'est pas
passé une étape ultérieure en fait
simplement manier ces formes là des
manières plus consciente qu auparavant
c'est la même chose à la politique qu'on
est conscient qui a un jeu de rôle dans
la politique une créature alisation une
communication qui a des éléments de
langage maintenant possède toutes ces
règles là et pourtant marche quand même
un peu au moins un moment des élections
non on n'en joue vous avez des dons un
champ d'application le médian on en joue
mais vous voyez les commentateurs
politiques qui il aime bien montrer aux
spectateurs qu'on peut être malin
c'est tellement triste d'ailleurs que le
commentaire politique n'est plus que de
cet ordre là vous voyez il a fait un
clin d'oeil parce qu'il voulait séduire
l'électorat féminin et voyez ici il a
utilisé tel mot parce que il veut gagner
bon sur ce plan là et ici finalement le
commentaire politique ressemble
drôlement aux commentaires sportifs quoi
c'est dire qu'on commande des tactiques
et des performances sur le web et sur le
plan d'eau d'une esthétique très pauvres
mais qui concerne d'effectivement des
jeux comme ça des faits oui mais vous
vivez au canada de nous la médiocratie
par exemple qui le livre qui vous a
révélé en france
les exemples venait presque tous du
canada à l'époque et tous les français
l'ont 30 à ceux qui l'ont lu en touriste
à la courbe est merveilleusement bien à
la france également
on est si proches les uns des autres
parce que le canada et la france et
l'occident général peut-être la
meilleure car c'est un livre curieuse
vous m'en parlez c'est un livre qui me
semble plus un pas intéressant quant à
l'oeil du lectorat que quand à sa
proposition de départ c'est à dire que
j'en parlais très modestement c'est le
livre que j'ai fait le plus vite
c'est un des livres que j'ai faits qui
m'importe le moins mais cependant je
pense qu'il mettait le doigt sur un
problème et ce qui m'a intéressé par
rapport à ce livre là c'est la réaction
c'est à dire que ici en espagne en
italie dans le monde arabe
beaucoup de gens en quelque sorte ont vu
en ce cette expression la médiocratie
que j'ai redéfini le le le sing de
quelque chose qu'on n'arrivait pas à
nommer bon et ce qui me heurte moi dans
ce succès et qui m'attriste
au fond c'est ce qu'il révèle à savoir
que beaucoup de gens ont considéré être
dans un ordre coercitif et médiocre à la
fois qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est à
dire qu'on est tenu de niveler par le
bas et par le moyen on est tenu d'être
moyen par exemple je vais parler encore
de télévision parce que c'est un exemple
que je donne souvent excusez moi mais
dans une émission de télévision
il faut que l'éclairage et sachez que
l'airé bon mais d'une certaine façon où
d'une façon certaine on pourra pas dire
que j'ai vu le film de godard hier où je
suis allé au théâtre et la personne et
éclairé de telle façon on va essayer ça
on veut mettre le projecteur ici ça
surtout ce sera environ reconnaître en
rien sa sera pas de la télé justement
parce que j'aime ici d'ailleurs c'est
que c'est une des rares émissions télé
où il ya de la pénombre
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est à la télé on
éclaire y plein pot on dirait qu'on est
dans une couveuse quoi mais mais mais
mais la médiocrité et la médiocratie
qu'est ce que c'est c'est contraindre à
la moyenne bon est bon au canada
l'embarras du choix pour les ex ange
mais j'ai bien vu par la réaction des
tops partout le courrier que je rajoute
pas de ses bras elle part donc on
souffre la médiocratie est arrivé le
même phénomène qu'en marie france
hirigoyen avait écrit son livre sur le
harcèlement moral
bon c'est un bon livre mais bon ça ça
ressemble plus à un joli conte qu'elle
était une certaine tenue mais qui
n'était pas non plus dès que la
découverte de l'amérique mais mais mais
qui révélait un problème et qui explique
une grande partie de son succès j'ai
senti quelque chose du genre et cela
témoigne d'un malaise
merci à la de nos d'avoir été m'ont
invité je rappelle que vos trois
premiers livres y en aura beaucoup
d'autres l'économie de la nature
l'économie de la foi et l'économie
esthétique trois premiers livres de ce
feuilleton théorie ne viennent de
paraître aux éditions lux merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]